hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay just got out
of the elementary school of horror hello
buddy give fun buddy what oh that's a
wormhole big tentacle monster movie
opening objective complete what a jump
button
oh hey hey Owen it's that guy Billy
no Billy you barely managed to escape
the CC facility this morning Chitty
Chitty Bang Bang for ah here but
engineer engineer please what fu try to
be a nerve ha ha it is dark
it's okay it's just a power outage
you guys are right up there oh [ __ ] no
uh-huh
how are you breathing stupid our two
remaining runners Clark and scruff well
hello I knew it was only a matter of
time before reach the transit hub you'll
find the train inoperable laughs you
bloody I don't like you already public
sector is already the unacceptable
recovery conditions ha ha can a lot of
people escape
did my partner oh I'm gonna kill you
dead
oh I'm gonna murder if I it's headed
what is well that is enough no point s
crew yeah get some elect winner of
stasis Vegas that I wasn't in space to
sing ah okay alright hang on I got this
clavo aw come on forget I wonder what
was that did you just throw something at
me
ah what the hell who is that
okay obviously this biker is not good
for brutes but what the hell it's never
done that before
have I bought a fruit yet in s face 100
I got this
holy [ __ ] art it's good oh yeah
come at me bro hahaha come at me bro Oh
miss haha Oh got you
just like the detonator the bed yeah
when it's hide him in town up the power
what did you do to piss him off so much
me are you blaming me Chris yeah leave
intelligence on my crew wouldn't shut up
about it
uh-huh why is it real yeah it's real one
using codes patterns are stored in our
heads
Mayans draws everything that's happening
on the station is happening because of
that marker yeah I have to get to it and
destroy it and I need struggles to tell
me how not that we're responsible for
this but here's strange man Isaac I
think that as a compliment okay so I
think yeah digging better no sass from
you without it we have no air in no
train sprawls got to have backup
batteries somewhere yes the solar arrays
up there their goodies if I can start
him up get some power in the train
you'll need someone to open the
collector panels I can do that in a
straw so keep him safe okay I didn't
hear any of that
let's mark it easy I'm his collecting
goodies am i going that way I think it
was the first time I have fought a brute
because I fought well it wasn't a brute
is a big thing but it wasn't you know
that and then that was the mini-boss
well it wasn't even really a boss I just
shot it in the yellow until it died no
then I shot the explosives and then it
blew up
gotcha huh look at all these goodies
they can hide from me no way that's a
lot of line racks I got a lot I need to
use the line rack line gun rather and I
need to use the old fire apparently what
the hell I know what that is that's a
mine can I deactivate it Dibby Dibby
little bit nope
sure yeah yeah yeah chair thank you so
much pop miss Peggy okay
aah what aah ok motor
yeah I love this game so much this bunch
ah ha ha life is so good Oh life is
beautiful kids our store nearby
all those two perfect camel hopefully
that doesn't disappear or something oh
come on maybe there's a store down there
that was so perfectly beautiful
anything else I could dumb and I guess
Carly haha I love love the dead new no
chapter 7 house trust early bid you can
hear noises three bills away he's gonna
give away my position
no he try getting focused I need to know
what he's trying to tell him he's crazy
that's what he's trying to tell him he's
crazy cuckoo nuts
so well is that all it's a suit ha
there's a store down here ok oh stop
sneaking up on me when I'm going to the
star ah yeah hey yeah anyone else anyone
oh okay still don't trust them flame
thrower schematic flamethrower schematic
um I'm gonna move this that is I've got
so many line racks
let's take up a lot of space I'll I'll
move it if I need lying rack later I'll
get it I definitely need more detonator
mines though okay debt mines dad
monetary Oh taxes
they only come in stacks of three now
this they must stack higher than that
right okay up to ten okay that should do
I mean I don't use a lot of really a
specialty thing yeah see ha now I like
the javelin because I discovered its
secondary fire I need to discover the
line rack secondary fire I should be
good
I'll go get up I'll go up and get the
the gold semiconductor later see what I
can do on the bench here
respectability oh that's nice you can
take um nodes out okay that's cool
um let's see here javelin guns okay but
I I love absolutely love this thing
death
what is it special
oh yeah just flashed it okay um I mean
damn it's damage is already so good I
don't even know why I need more um load
capacity with Oh the wind I don't even
know what the all fire is but I don't
know uh
I have to go that way anyway so let's
see whip and then and reload speed
should do fine yeah that's no keep one
does for special occasions alright bring
it on
actually now that I have upgraded that
I'm just gonna grab the ammo because I'm
going to be using it almost exclusively
for the next few fights yeah mate yeah
mate
okay now we're all sick I haven't gotten
many suits come out it's the only one
I've gotten so far is this ah no damn
you can't get fit get yeah but yeah
crushed by the body you were hiding over
under over under what though where'd you
come from
you are ugly
okay well I'm going to the solar array
for power Wow
first you get the money I'm an engineer
yeah I could do that it looks like a
docking pod that runs in the soil is
floating at the bottom of the shaft this
chute red tip to move objects that oh
look at that
hot damn
okay all right then
is that says shoot that nope no I should
not lets you you're a body part I don't
want to see you
alright was this thing Larry I don't
know um oh shoot red tip whoa whoa
yeah come here come here come here come
hither I gave it my come hither look and
it did not respond power no power no
yeah I thought you could hide from me
Oh God oriented the ground there we go
oh no don't land hotel yeah yeah all
expert will beam
I didn't do much I just shot it repaired
what did I do
he's doing can you hear this [ __ ] this
is going to be whoa what the hell oh
okay
Z is Orion to ground okay
I love the zero Z fly it bums me out
because it looks like dead space 3 won't
have a lot of 0 T flying that was one of
the cool things that I mean if it all
takes place on that planet then me
trouble oh hello lime gun ha ha
got ya come here
no you have a spike right fighting there
it is anyone else anyone else want to
step oh oh no to think so alright
who do we got well we got Oh
that missiny I probably missed a bunch
of floating items out there
okay long elevator this is a big
elevator ooh ah look at that oh look at
the view it's beautiful it's gorgeous
actually quite gorgeous oh how long is
it
life [ __ ] ever come on go ha ha ha
yellow oh no aah yeah yeah
ah
guru God ah
kya haha
do it do it no not today not ever I
don't want to buy any I respect the
organisation I donate every other week
day ah ah hello come on please
Oh God what's the alternate fire what
the hell was that
what is that but it's a time - I know
go go go
ah Gaea man those are those big things I
bought before
ah no don't bore me bro take some of
that ah oh oh you gave me an item thank
you no now today wow there's a lot of
them ah ah reload
suddenly items just dropped from
everywhere I'm out of air when did I run
out of oh the windows broke up that was
a lot of those big things to just hop on
an elevator did that seem cos strange to
you what the hell is that
oh it's those tuber things oh okay
anyway but actually now let me keep
going I gotta find a safe point anyway
oh I hear one well it's to kill me
it's a stasis bomb
did you forget stasis mom why didn't I
know about that
nope got you warm everybody killed you
think oh man that stasis last a long
time
holy crap I saw one of those earlier in
the brute fight I didn't know what the
brick of was you doubt it could block
the brood up forever fire sick fire
stick is still stasis all right where
where where where
Oh there Bartek come here sis just wore
off on ok got that um
womp yeah God I didn't know why did they
spit there oh come on I don't have time
for this all right I'll find a save
point later um that's all the time I got
for this of it thank you guys so much
for watching and as always see you
in the next part okay I thought for a
second to drop me at the beat hey thanks
again for watching I'll see you in the
name
bye bye